con su avance Fiona sigue dejando
devastación a su paso al tocar el suelo
este lunes en República Dominicana el
fenómeno natural derribo árboles y cortó
líneas eléctricas
con una velocidad de traslación de 13
kilómetros por hora y se desplaza hacia
el noroeste de la República Dominicana
con daños materiales en viviendas e
inundaciones que obligaron a evacuar a
cientos de personas en la isla el
gobierno también suspendió la actividad
laboral con alerta roja en la mayoría
del territorio
ya era reconstruir de nuevo que hay que
ir ahora en Puerto Rico el temporal dejó
un apagón general desde el domingo con
fallos en la electricidad de toda la
isla y también a con cientos de
evacuados después de la advertencia de
los meteorólogos de que los niveles de
agua podrían ser históricos en el país
está disponible en la escuela Carlos
Escobar nos estamos orientando a las
personas la parte
y esa que hay que dejarlos con las
mascotas tenemos un refugio
puede llevar su mascotas allí la gente
Todavía no se ha recuperado del huracán
María de 2017 que dejó miles de muertes
y ahora cinco años después ven como sus
casas vuelven a sufrir daños ahora se
espera que Fiona abandone la isla y tome
más fuerza a medida que avanza hacia el
norte